nivea menti sur le même support panneau
d'entrée d'agglomération
donc j'aimerais savoir je vous pose la
question ici est ce que toutes les
routes
il y a quelques années cette salle
comptait le double d'apprentis ici les
gars ancion du moniteur permet de mieux
former les candidats au code de la route
mais avec la réforme du permis de
conduire
les candidats peuvent s'inscrire via des
plateformes dédiées aux codes ou à la
conduite on y trouve des supports
pédagogiques des outils et des tarifs a
priori abordable on se retrouve dans une
situation où il n'y a pas de formateurs
le candidat il est livré à lui-même
lorsqu'il utilise internet
c'est vrai il y a ceux qui tombent sur
les bons sites
il y en a d'autres qui utilisent des
sites qui sont moins complet donc en
réalité la formation n'est pas toujours
comme il faut voyant les candidats
avivées par la suite
possédant déjà le
le code ne passant pas par la salle la
salle on est obligés d'adapter notre
formation en fonction de cela cherchez à
savoir exactement quel est le niveau de
connaissance du candidat pour savoir
comment adapter nos cours de conduite
dans sept autres écoles evariste forme
environ 130 élèves parents du code à la
conduite avec ses candidats au permis
il réalise des cours particuliers
adaptés à chacun d'eux ils créent une
proximité quasi inexistants dans les
écoles de conduite en ligne on va
prendre rendez vous pour faire une
évaluation de départ regard desquels
vous avez fait et à partir de là on va
mettre ensemble un plan global de
sécurité routière est-ce qu'il est
sérieux quand l'élève aura pratiquement
chaque jour
en attaque on est fiers je suis persuadé
qu'ils a pas de sujet pour avoir une
date d'examen pour la conduite des
inscriptions en candidat libre pour est
possible sans avoir à passer par une
auto-école
de quoi faire monter la grogne chez les
moniteurs il prévoit une mobilisation ce
lundi 11 février